welcome to this video yeah this is blitz
kibitzing again I only as a seer looking
for some good games to kibitz on so
going to check here what can we do there
are some good players on let's go with
my old nemesis omegas first well it goes
in this game here playing wide yeah this
is the national master kankri wallows
off and as usual he's got some endgame
on the board this time not a dead one
where he is playing on time this is just
better for white let's see how is faring
against frederico here player with the
brazil flag yeah white is much better
due to his better space and the two
bishops he sg5 coming and this would be
difficult for black to meet white has
all the time in the world to improve we
can even put bishop f1 h3y em this is
what i would play at least activating
the bishop to the to the fullest but you
can also go g5 like on a gas did here
just breaking through g6 is the threat
yeah a wide should probably take on age
six and try to invade yeah we threw
cleric g7 asst debatable actually we
should she fall that's an interesting
decision not sure if I i wants to get g6
yeah i see the point he wants them to
have g6 available that's very very good
yes what wants to take on age six and
then have rook g6 this is why he traded
the light squared bishops not sure if
you want to take sorry if you want to
take it now you can but not necessary
Bishop e1 n
I'm not sure where he's going really
maybe no he wants to take I mean he's
really very pragmatic he just wants to
win it doesn't care how we win so you
can also just shuffle and win on time
which could be possible here letting the
teachers does that I mean I have my
experiences here it's not necessarily
trying to win the position and white has
plenty of ideas to do to do that you
could for example you could try to bring
the king or where but like it's doing
something okay rook g5 and Bishop age
form yeah then King the king around
their King see 3d so and so on ki king
over to the Kings side is a way forward
Jack a he immediately goes for the
breakthrough that's also good probably
rock g6 channel g6 King g7 Bishop h4
checker that looks very problematic
check yeah and where are you going now
now c6 was falling rook e8 probably a
rook c8 I'm sorry or rookie just one of
those checks lat 44 effects on time so
just very very loud and going to reduce
it a little bit I recently had to turn
up the volume to get some skype calls in
okay this was typical Bullock us grind
let's see what else is there I'm plenty
of titled players around I'm just trying
to select something something
interesting or something of special
interest let's say there are many many
good games let's go here with go on
playing wide against more on Donna yeah
gone that I
room to always forget his name Igor yen
vy off there's one of those yeah well
let's not talk about it he's playing
whitey against Maradona he's also one of
those rook against root guys so I have
my fair share of experience against him
so here Kings Indian Petrosian system
that was and I think go up with white
here is a little bit better yeah f4 is
an interesting movie a blasting open the
center not playing passively waiting for
f5 but trying to open up the position
yourself ideally white would want
something like it takes a frog Bishop
takes f1 and even a 45 for why this
would be really nice and if black is not
reacting here like Bishop maybe 96 is a
move yeah yeah f5 is also an idea not
sure about it if it is good but it could
be could be an interesting idea gains
lots of space right and well black can
play 96 but this is really not much
counter play plus those tactics are like
f6 and things like that what can also
just yeah build up here something like
this you have plenty of time this night
is nice on d6 but it is not like black
has an active plan while white can go
King h1 yeah look f2 group to g one g
for something like that long-term the
best that black can do is at some point
take on f5 and try to play e5e form
freeing the bishop but i don't see that
happening so why does definitely in good
shape yeah rook f3 and tending rook h3
is also a move here yeah mentee went for
that
now that doesn't look too great for
black rook h3 is a very very problematic
move and if you do let's say h5 yeah
this even Bishop g5 may be coming and
the queen is without any square yeah h5
is not on how do you even protect h6 you
move the green back to e7 it's also f5
f6 yeah at the thread and this is this
is very very dangerous now for black not
sure how he keeps how he stays on the
board retakes on f5 it just goes bang
yeah yeah root page 3 is maybe just
possible h5 and even g form as brutal as
it looks but if it crashes through it it
just crashes through and wins rook a
jade or something Wow G a G takes h5 he
takes f5 age six or something age six
looks interesting but maybe this is not
helping that much sometimes pushing
those pawns is not helping yeah but ok
black is threatening f4 am so you
probably don't have time for King h1 or
something like that maybe just taking
one at five at first and then and then
continue let's tricky it's a somewhat
tricky position
he takes f 59 f 50 Bishop f5 and that's
a relatively simple solution but
probably a good one here age six is a
huge threat King King has to stay here
Bishop age six is interesting I thought
the King age seven is better but of
course black is somewhat on the ropes at
some just wide attacking with almost all
pieces and black has yeah very little to
play form on his own Bishop h6 ruchi aid
takes everything and queen g5 wins
apiece yeah bishop edge sings h6 just
wins the game now I think well what what
else here black cannot take on age 60
straight directly mated Bishop h6
ambition f6 you take f8 and black can
resign yeah like will resign now I guess
this is this absolutely no play will
move black resign yeah that was a really
good game by go here the white player I
think looked like that okay cannot be
one hundred percent sure but it looked
looked nice I mean around here with f4
and and five this was really really
strong like was was in huge trouble and
Queen edge form yeah the same
accelerated the down 40 of blacks
position okay let's see what else is
they have to check on the right hand
side what games are on I am let's do
this Sir John against all agus so John
earn is very strong I am yanos go gaggy
do jihadis sorry yeah from from Greece
and
25 something I have played him a lot
with early accounts i only had him twice
with fifty percent score with Chaz
explained but I have played him a lot
earlier is very strong and it's an evil
Eve matched pairing here so let's have a
look what I guess is playing black hair
he played the Queens gambit declined and
he has a nice position again he has this
passed pawn the c-4 pond and he has
control in this position white basically
has just one plane here f 3 a 4 and if
you look at that black has all pieces
basically offer pieces directed against
this d5 bishop on f5 both rook so e 4 is
very difficult to achieve so difficult
to play this foolishness wide however
it's possible that we are talking about
a fortress-like situation where it is
difficult for a black to organize a
winning progress that's really possible
III is a weakness which is securely
protected by King and rook and while
both whoops actually and it's not so
clear how black intends to him to
improve his position and somehow
strengthen the tech IAM black only have
some yeah has moves exactly and with
this king-size pawns fr their form
that's that's really the idea that comes
to mind right would be that would be
difficult maybe maybe on f4 white can
white just shuffle after a form I habit
if you take a couple of times only three
then still the sea pawn will run this is
also getting to zoosk one territory with
Bishop d3 now is a big threat now black
is just flat-out winning here I guess
maybe you can can you play EF
taking on F form EF hmm he takes FG
takes f that's hard to believe that like
shouldn't win here is just so
overwhelming but still it takes FG takes
every kid seven lucky seven Bishop e2
whereas where is the progress here
rookie 7 would be seven Bishop e2 for
and why it is just just staying a dozen
doesn't do anything
a black has all the time in the world he
does not have to rush things White has
absolutely no active idea you cannot
even play rook c1 intending rookie one I
mean despite the fact that it might be
losing the rook trade but on rook see
wonders ruby three coming the only gas
has one minute more on the clock oh it's
accidentally repeated here I think it
would would play on time otherwise okay
so a draw in a position where black is
is just better but maybe there is no no
way forward that's possible let's see we
got a new game to to look at I prefer
five minute because you have more time
to do commentary and it's simply a
little bit more yeah it's a little bit
of higher quality in comparison ah wait
let's do this this is this is three
minute I know but the white player here
is some is Alexander Milosevic yeah so
super GM playing Igor Giro f he stayed
known name in there but that's that's
really more savage it's something that
is pretty much clear there is a list
where ICC handled some attached to real
names in those cases where there are no
names in there they use other
information that they accumulated
somewhere else for example online
tournaments or something like that and
this is really more savage playing white
playing against ischium let's see what
that is Hisham hound ushi this is one of
the strongest on gm's from Africa yeah I
think I'm do she is from see from
Algeria or Morocco I am sorry about that
I am I don't know it exactly yeah it's
very strong good 2500 GM so let's see
here this is coming from Scandinavian
defense
and merasa which is why he's got like
three extra ponds and but it's a messy
position and well and white has one of
those kings icons but in the process
also has opened up his King and today
maybe rookie eight now but that's Bishop
Queen g4 check er no quieres no no great
pin and there's s who I am also but he
prefers to yeah this is a good practical
movie on the bishop on g3 is them is
sort of the yeah it's the Dogu k one
catches the bishop maybe it's a good pin
the bishop 1g3 keeps the whole King side
yeah i tidied up and secured so it's a
kind of an insurance policy for them for
the White King and now the bishop a
three drops yeah yeah this will moral we
win this that said my joseph e.m resigns
maybe I try to follow him if he's
playing a couple of more games is always
entertaining to watch him very
enterprising inventive player and if
he's not playing anymore we will look
for something else I'm following him
hoping for a new game look I give it a
little bit of time I'm not sure if he's
immediately trying to get a new game
maybe he's preferring three minutes
that's very likely actually but for that
from that good player we are we okay
with it and there is no totally
outstanding five minute game to watch
some good ones but nothing really
brilliant okay I keep an eye I keep an
eye and if he is playing a little bit
more I will go back to rossovich until
this happens or not we look at this the
end of the three minute game between
black player sooner Burke Hanson and
widest you know who that is the hollow
shank off and i am from Russia
I am black has a an extra chance black
has an actual piece and probably we win
this spite the the time issues both have
little time 20 20 ish seconds ah ok that
wasn't that interesting anyway so the
following surely worked and now we are
looking at murasa would share playing
black against Melek own that's mica
karttunen yeah I played him before right
one out of three in the five-minute pool
and this is three minutes the
three-minute pool the order pairing
often referred as the pool yeah we have
a collie opening not very aggressive for
white at first but this is actually
often leading to interesting positions
like here a 93 Bishop g7 White has d 5
which is very sharp actually or white
has also e4 I believe but d5 is quite
interesting going for a pawn sacrifice
if black accepted so that's not very
common but all they are interesting this
is interesting night to d6 but isn't
this a little bit like a lone warrior
the snide only six it's not doing that
much ok morrow is simply hacking the
night and now Knight to c6 that's an
interesting decision now he's not
bothering with Bishop c6 which blocks up
the position but develops quickly yeah
and now we see that he really has a good
position here I am black has an
excellent development and he can't even
take everything off now I'm play d5
after which yeah like night d 3 Queen d3
ok this is also a good move but taking
everything and then d5 was interesting
to get the two pawns and the center
going and can't just claim that the
bishop on you is heaven is much better
than the one on c1 which is a claim that
is probably very successful yeah maybe
here what about Queen a six or before
something like that attacking the pawn
didn't do that yeah a 5 a-4 is also an
interesting idea trying to play for a 3
and also sort of anticipating why it's
idea to play b3 to support the c four
points that you can always take this be
three-point appearing Jim what is this
this is fairly solid for black but
probably not not brilliant and night
before our King white could take a four
so he's preparing night before actually
with Queen a six ok when I before yes
that looks good also defy their that's
powerful player by Monroe sivad ship but
just strong they are pushing the d7
point it was a passive porn and now it
turns into a strong porn with this D for
possibly see form those attacking moves
why just blundered a 2 here and this
will cost him the game and he was in
trouble anyway but if you give up the a
pawn they're black now just goes back to
before or 2 C 3 and then you'll play a 2
and promoters poor nets that's probably
nothing that white can save ever yeah
probably just backhand a2m now White has
no attack you can go f5 take on your six
but there is no attack really and the
combination of the outside passer on the
a file and the bishop on the long
diagonal is just dead Liam the pawn go
we'll just crash through can even go
Bishop g7 TM okay went for the
horizontal cover let's say we only know
a to come on not
okay yeah Black is he is so comfortable
here you can do many things night see to
also not blunder in the routine oh yeah
yeah better move the rook and now you
can take everything off Queenie 5 is
also on a queen is Jeff to trade and
forced resignation yeah that was a
really convincing win by more savage of
course he's really strong player i mean
at in his best and his best he was some
like number two in the world there for a
very very short period of time
admittedly it's very close to being
number one by raging actually so on it's
a clearly a case where he is the better
player compared to and i am yeah this is
this guy is probably around my level and
if i play against more oh I just get
crushed at least handed almost all games
i don't think i ever played him on the
ISS see i played many top players at
least once or twice but not not morose
ovitch okay um let's have a look at its
taking his time till the new game starts
this is actually an advantage of them of
the challenge system sometimes if you do
cubed sing if they play those those
little matches they just continue to
play a game of the game of the game so
you don't have any breaks between the
single games okay um if he starts a new
game we will jump back to that
automatically but to this point let's
watch a little bit of this i am here we
have grandma satanic playing black
against been MIA cozy and don't know
that guy no name in them some italian
italian player but utterly kia already
has an excellent position he has a good
player against f2 white cannot move the
rook which means he will probably lose
the exchange
as the rook leaving means f two faults
and it shaped me to follow so you will
win at least the exchange on f on
everyone and the white also yeah it does
not have any of any active plan this was
out of them a Dutch defense almost 93 f
five and then why'd went with d3 the way
I see it white played a very unassuming
setup and very often resign this leads
to big trouble if you against Dutch
setups if you play in annemiek fashion
somewhat passive fashion you quite often
will simply get wiped out there because
the leg setup is so aggressive okay that
was a fairly short view on this game and
merasa which unfortunately has
disconnected so we will look at some
other games it's not like he's the only
play of interest competing at the moment
I have a game ham pork or with white
pork who I don't know that guy from
Brazil again against gone yeah I go is a
good player I played him a lot it's just
like he's doing those time things but
it's a very strong player actually
always around 2,400 something okay here
we have a very close position but go ah
playing black has already accomplished a
nice space advantage with pawns on c4d
form so it's got a clamp on the position
we could also if we want I could also it
could flip the board yeah but let's
let's keep it like that it's getting
irritating if I start flipping the ball
all the time yeah black space advantage
is very good and t if was the first to
get in a 5 so try to open up the FR they
played luca a 72 possibly play rook a
eight but now wide switched his
attention to the move f3 so the FR has
opened it's not quite clear maybe and
probably I think if black now should
also um rethink his strategy Oh again I
thought maybe Bishop h3 rook f7 would be
on but now that why it has basically
committed suicide on the queenside you
will just take the pawns
yeah white was in huge trouble he had
this passive position without any active
plan this is of course a five-minute
game yet before you get irritated by the
times we it's mostly three and five
minute that is plain and this was a
five-minute game yeah why it is really
ciao almost lost them black can go for
pure queens i play with a three trying
to promote the pawn or kids still play
Bishop age three it's both possible he's
better on on both flanks especially bad
out of the night on d 2 and the bishop
won't see to this is really just
completely yeah the coast pieces are
simply terrible
yeah the most important thing if you are
black in such a position you have total
control is trying to not allow any
counter play and improve your position
to the utmost they're not striking too
early simply because white is so passive
he can not do anything so it's a good
idea to improve everything until it's on
the best possible squares and only then
strike not trying to be quick or
anything there's no real need to to win
quickly it's important to win in a way
that there's nothing happening yantian
white actually has blundered III that's
a good thing that often comes with being
patient in winning positions quite often
the opponent being in this sad position
will make a mistake and make it much
easier to for yourself sometimes in
playing some little moves that improve
your position is actually winning
quicker than the idea that is more
brutal in a way because yeah keeping the
opponent guessing what's coming next is
often the most the most dangerous way to
go and then they make a mistake because
they have no active good move that
megamistake yeah here black is some just
fantastic shape Finch a towing the night
and basically and preparing Queen III
yep that's that's a nice invasion with
Queen III rook f2 got an excellent
excellent position check black can even
take on c3 I think
yeah black I think he is he's out how to
to kill him now here keeping or taking
more pawns it's not really that great
but yeah he ain't probably has no no big
choice yeah why this home was forcing
that we should take c4 is this may be an
idea no didn't do that maybe 93 other
this night on g2 is really a funny piece
placement but ultimately it's not doing
that much and if white now has to trade
Queen takes there is a thread Bishop f2
which looks decisive really a Bishop g2
I'm sorry Bishop g2 check don't see a
move here at all Bishop g2 check King v1
and then I just discover checks King h7
that's not so not so difficult we should
do to check Kings you want Luke take C
to checkmate is the threat and white can
basically only give up all its pieces to
prevent it yeah rook h8 depa desperado
stuff or queen g1 bishop f1 those kind
of move that will lead to made a little
bit a little bit later quite resign I
didn't find our play will move simply
because there is none okay let's see
next game yeah maybe go for this italica
game Italian aesthetic playing Tasha
massa hmm QR let's check who that is
aryana slump out so it's not plague that
often or the IC may be relatively new
here it's played some one minute game
that's a young player he's some let me
think about it
probably 17 16 or 17 years and I am one
of the promising German juniors and he's
up on time and he has got he's got but
it's got a lost position right why does
attacking every piece yeah beat you
before aah everything's hanging so this
is a matter of sort of like trying to
not lose on time and is we won't look up
yeah probably I can just retreat the aam
bishop and white is a rook up so yeah
this game only continues because it's in
one increment time control and total
dick is on 17 seconds while Lampard has
got one minute so they they will
continue this I think is playing really
slowly probably am I mean always or
already a little bit yeah he resigned
himself probably a little bit to his
fate that he would lose on time but Jim
at the beginning it was nothing do a boy
it wasn't difficult to make light
warheads and having quick moves sorry
quick moves but he was really really
slow he isn't that slow normally i
played him a number of times in the
five-minute pool and it's not like he's
a speed demon but he's not slow he
wasn't this game though sometimes it
happens if people switch their equipment
yeah they have fun new mouse or playing
on only on their mobile phone even that
happened yeah I played some blitz games
on my mobile mobile phone once during a
barbecue after I had some beers this was
quite funny i mean i think i lost all
games can okay so let's see do we have
an attractive game here let's do this
that's a lick with the wide against
issue you should wash on do she writes
oh okay we have a Sicilian maroc see
out of 93 though and issue me as is
taking early on before a very early
stage yeah we are now in a line that is
called the Google it's a system with an
early capture on the 405 is interesting
and now be three is a good move this is
from the game koala cards another singh
feared cup after a form be four is good
for wide and answer league will always
not doing that I thought you will know
that he's a very good theoretical player
um in term Wow okay that's surprising in
this position black should be quite ok
but if white would have played before
immediately we would have gotten to this
game where Karen had a really nice
position had cards and on the ropes was
very close to winning his eighth eighth
game in a row Bishop to e6 97 this kind
of loss or this move yeah I think black
with now rook a to invading on the a
thought should be all right unless
there's some tactic based on the night
on b6 but while it's not well developed
yeah the bishop is still on f1 yes not
castle and getting his rook on h1 into
play I think this is a this is a really
failed opening them somehow are
interesting that's interesting move see
takes D takes and maybe before yeah it's
art Alex idea no II five is this idea of
course yeah if the night now moves these
seven drops but there is this year
exactly there's this move attacking the
the rook takes takes be born and rook
the ADA probably not King takes yeah I
looked yet and the problem is that black
is having all pieces in play from a
material point of view that's not bad
why it has got two pieces but like is so
active when I cannot play rocked it to
them
hmm not so easy how does black get his
rook on the aid into the game if he
plays Bishop d3 whiteville maybe Teague
and castle maybe bishop see to hear
Bishop c2 if white develops his Bishop
to c4 disruptive one yeah I think this
is good just taking now on b3 that's
actually with check check some other
discovery probably not and now where we
just bishop e6 or something I there
that's much stronger no no this is not
strong I have a strong play about how do
she is just pinning the bishop 1 of 1
against the rook so white is still
suffering from this lack of development
he lost lots of time in the opening face
o.o 97 made black has rookie in one year
rookie one rookie one Bishop e2 maybe
Wow is this good for what what do what a
position Wow yeah this is funny funny
Bishop H Bishop b5 for Luke age one
Bishop d7 and 97 checkmate it's almost
impossible to prevent them wow that's
cool white gotten out of the blue
counter-attack tonight see aid Wow
I don't know it still looks very
dangerous for for black any any kind of
check will be a checkmate yeah like this
rook 28 but our the night on b6 is such
a strong piece at the night killed the
rooks completely a black resigns Wow
yeah it was actually a very good game by
ischium at first but then I sonic
somehow got his pieces coordinated and
probably here there is the the key
moment when the night came to c 8 it
immediately look dangerous probably you
should have done something else instead
of this loop move Wow very nice very
nice end of this game okay let's see
let's do one more game at least what do
we have
here GM both black one that I didn't
kibbutz on yet we've got Lord flesh
heart white player from Denmark against
blue shark 23 who is blue shark 20 the
tea poet all nigh okay that's a veteran
GM from Hungary rly he is a gem for for
a long time since the 90s I'd say and
he's playing black here and he's got
very little development going for him no
95 that that's difficult 95 you cannot
go f5 because of night to e6 and if you
cannot go f5 black is probably forced to
take on d5 after which night xe4 gives
white fantastic lead in development
that's very difficult from like Knight
takes e4 now how do you develop g69 f6
checkmate is a pretty pretty clear
refutation of what a google way to try
to develop yeah somehow a tone I he even
played the ton of porn was it seems
plays a sharp creative player sometimes
this is type of player gets into trouble
when they are being a little bit too
creative I wonder is there maybe Bishop
c12 f form does this type of my DM it's
also interesting intending Bishop a
three on be to this Bishop is really
doing absolutely nothing also a 5-yard
could be a move Queenie to attacking a
six and a seven that's probably good yep
double attack found by Lord flesh heart
topsham wonder where people come up with
their names but
it is probably a yeah it's probably very
often done in a moment where you didn't
really think much about about it I mean
my my chest explain name is also not
exactly the result of of a longer
thought process I was just sitting there
and when I intended to upload a video on
youtube I just wanted to show it to a
friend of mine whom yeah you asked me if
I could do such a blitz video with
commentary in German at the time I was
just recognizing okay I need an account
on youtube I haven't I never really
looked at it much can they had to use
something and so on I went from Chaz
explained this was somehow coming to my
mind so and that it's stuck and when I
when I am I did this also never really
thought about that I would actually be
perceived as my name yeah it's just a
channel name and well okay it is it is
working I guess okay here White has some
still kept an advantage but it didn't
feel like it was the best possible way
to continue why does Scott of pawn and
we'll get d5 as well but black managed
to get opposite colored bishops and at
least a bishop end game if rooks are
being traded um would certainly be yeah
probably a horrible wonder what wine is
doing here look III and then look if
I've looked a bit strange he I think
what he can do is he can get d5 with his
bishop trying to get this without a rook
trade it's not easy actually a bishop d5
this probably f6 something like that
yeah white wants to get the d5 pawn
without trading looks maybe King f1e to
d3 as an idea trying to cover this with
the king
and black wants to get the d4 pawn trade
those two parts and ideally somehow get
looks off to draw the opposite colored
bishops end game like this yeah exactly
takes takes bishop c3 and but Bishop g8
yeah or this move as possible which
right which allows white to keep two
pawns yeah those end games they're
always tricky why these two points up
the parts are relatively close to one
another this is a win or not and there
are many a situation that are definitely
not winning and I'm not sure about this
kingi to now wins it wins the bishop
okay again kingi to Winston bishop come
on what is what doing here he's playing
it in a way that even allows black some
chaney and saving chances I would maybe
maybe white still wins yeah you you get
King g62 f7 to g7 and pick up the edge
porn yeah okay but came g2 earlier it
was funnier but okay sometimes you do
the the weirdest things and blitz kingi
to hear was winning of course and here
again King g2 is not that difficult just
going to g2 and trap this okay do we
have one more really really good game
what do we have no no real well known
players around okay let's let's go with
pseudo sonic again he's really a good
player enjoy watching him it's a he
really tries to win by HS means and
tries to play good moves okay this came
out of a goon felt quite a sharp
position material is not equal like as a
pawn down but black has a fantastic g7
bishop on the long diagonal he's got a
form working for him and look on the
area black has yeah this is a little bit
typical for the Greenfeld ya black ass
this
active pieces Bishop's on d7 g 7 and
guys quite well coordinated but wyd of
course has the d7 porn the d6 bond it
could go to the seventh sometimes for
example here but Luke d7 seems to stop
it I'd be surprised if white is good
here I think blacks activity should at
least give him a decent game but of
course this is a very this is the
position Bishop takes default we should
be for Queen D for Dukey one as a
typical idea rook e1 and resigns oops ya
like like has won the Queen right
blundered here but he's just continue
like nothing ever happened okay who is
so I play x-ray Daniel for San Esteban
don't know that one it's not playing
five minute much why so in this room
innate who you very often see players
who are not really appearing on my
channel as opponents because they don't
play five minute they concentrate on
playing three minute so yeah I hope you
enjoyed this kibbutz video was 45
minutes of good blitz shares our think
some interesting moments and term and
thrilling games um yeah I will do some
more of those of course during the time
up to Christmas so yeah check out the
channel there will be uploads here and
there of those those bonus videos thanks
for watching